what about the the argument that sort of
the employer
uh the capitalist takes on risk
so
the yeah versus the employee who's just
there doing the labor the the capitalist
is actually putting up a lot of risk
what's uh
uh are they not in sort of aggregating
this organization and taking this giant
effort hiring a lot of people
aren't they taking on risk that this is
going to be a giant failure so first of
all there's risk
almost in everything you undertake any
project that begins now and ends in the
future it takes a risk that between now
and that future something's going to
happen that makes it not work out
i mean i got into a cab before i came
here today in order to do this with you
i took a risk i could the cab could have
been in an accident the lightning could
have hit us a bear could have eaten my
left foot who the hell no shouldn't i
reward you for the risk you took no hold
it a second let's do this step by step
so everybody's taking a risk i always
found it wonderful you talk about risk
and then you imagine it's only some of
us who take a risk
let's go with the worker in the with the
capitalist
that worker
he moved his family from
michigan to pennsylvania to take that
job
he had he made a decision to have
children
they are teenagers they're now in school
at a time when their friendships are
crucial to their development you're
going to yank him out of the school
because his job is gone he took an
enormous risk
to do that job every day
to forestall all the other things he
could have done he was taking a risk
that this job would be here tomorrow
next month next year
he bought a house which americans only
do with mortgages which means he's now
stuck he has to make a monthly payment
if you
make a mistake
you capitalist
he's the one who's gonna you're a
capital you've got a lot of money
otherwise you wouldn't be in that
position
you got you've got a cushion he doesn't
if you investigate you'll see that in
every business i've ever been and i've
been involved in a lot of them so you
think it's possible to actually measure
risk or is your basic argument is
there's risk involved in a in a lot of
both the working class and the
bourgeoisie the capitalist that's right
and it's a worker the worker would never
come and say
because she's been taught right
um
i want this payment a wage
for the work i do
and i want this page
this payment for the risk i take well
there's some level of communication like
that you you have acknowledgement of
dangerous jobs but that's probably built
into the salary all those kinds of
things you you unders but you're not
incorporating you don't have a full
spectrum of risk you don't believe that
this country is now being
literally transformed from below by an
army of workers who work at amazon uh
fast food joints you know what their
complaint is
it's killing us
we get paid [ __ ]
and it's killing us there is no
relationship except in the minds of the
defenders of capitalism between the
ugliness the difficulty the danger of
labor on the one hand and the wage let
me give you just a couple of examples
this is my this my job this my life what
i do all right the median income
of a child care worker in the united
states right now as we speak
is 11 and 22 cents an hour
median so 50 make less 50 make more
the median income for car park attendant
is several dollars per hour higher than
that
what does the car park attendant do he
stares at your car
for many hours to make sure that nobody
comes and grabs it
maybe
he parks it and he moves it around to
get it in and out
by any measure that i know of that makes
any rational sense
being in charge of of toddlers two three
four year olds who are at the key moment
of mental formation the first five years
to do to give that a lower salary than
you give the guy who watches your car
come on i know how to explain it
gender explained all kinds of issues the
the car park people are are males and
the day the child care people are female
and that that in our culture is a very
big marker of what but the one who said
only the economics professor
nobody else
says this stuff because in economy i
don't know if you were familiar with our
profession but we have something which
we call
marginal product this is a this is a
fantastic i i was a mathematician before
i became an economist i loved
mathematics i i specialized in
mathematics so i know mathematics pretty
well
what economists do is silly is childish
but they think it's mathematics or it's
5th grade it isn't
but
think for a minute what it means
to suggest that you can identify the
marginal product
of a factor of production like a worker
in in the textbook when it's taught i've
taught this stuff
i hold my nose but i teach it then i
explain to students what i just taught
you is horse [ __ ] but i first i teach it
what is the marginal product if it might
be useful the notion is
if you take away one worker right now
from the pile what will be the
diminution
of the output that's the marginal
product of that worker measured by
the amount of the output that diminishes
the output of the raw product of the
product usually in real terms so
physical not not the value you could do
a value but it's really more the
physical you're having i mean i there is
a transformation thing that will i'd
love to talk to you about
about value it's so interesting
i'll be glad to talk to you about value
and price and all of that but i just
want to get to the
hegel who's marx's teacher has a famous
line
you can't step in this in the same river
twice
and the argument is you and the river
have changed between the first and the
second time so it's a different you and
it's a different you can choose not to
pay attention to that just you can't
claim you're not doing that you can't
claim that you can actually do that
because you can't there is no way to do
that so the the meaning that you can't
just remove a worker and have a clean
mathematical calculation of the effect
that it has on the output right because
too many other things are going on too
many things are changing and you cannot
assume
much as you want to
that the outcome on the output side is
uniquely determined by the change you
made on the input side can't do that
even in the uh even in the average it's
not going to work out you can take look
mathematics is full of abstractions you
can abstract you can say as as we do in
economics ketter is parabus you know
everything else held constant
but you have to know what you just did
you held everything you know why you do
that because you can't do that in the
real world that's not possible you
better account for that otherwise you're
mistaking the abstraction
from the messy reality you abstracted
from to get the abstraction
as a quick tangent if we somehow went
through a thought experiment or an
actual experiment of removing every
single economist from the world would be
better off or worse off much better off
okay
economics and i'm one you know i'm
talking about myself
you